it's too tall your village is [ __ ] this
allowed me about your village it's like
every time you see some basic technology
you're like oh that's the muslin holy
[ __ ] I think a sensation that I've never
experienced and I always hear people
talk about isn't the runner's high
oh yeah no there's no hell no I'm like
what what people talk about it and one
of my friends he was like splaining it
to me it's like you get to this point
where you're running and you can just
get this crazy adrenaline rush and it
makes you want to get more yeah and I'd
exactly it does awful look at experience
I would never do one know exactly and
they're trying to like entice me with
this you gotta just get to that point
where you're running about 70 miles and
then you hit this - [ __ ] 17 miles have
your car a bicycle rollerblades human
invention I bet you believe in this
stuff
oh this it goes I love it when I'm sore
thank you no I don't actually
I'm super wimpy about it cuz I ain't
around a couple of like brutish human
beings and the way they talk about short
so I generally I just I'm just called a
[ __ ] I swim that's my name now there's
a human sign your body is telling you
hey stop knockin no more heavy water
I've had enough it's just not natural to
like it we're so Muriel she said the
seagulls oh I love it when I'm sore she
goes you know you don't like it when
you're sore like when you get a good
workout it makes you feel like you'll
accomplish something right okay I can
kind of understand the feeling of
accomplishment but that's a displacement
of feeling yes so we tested this out so
I had to do a circuit right
and the next day she we had church and
we had a wake up at 9 a.m. and next
thing you're not on my hey are you you
want to skip Church thing she goes so
what she's doing on nicer man I like her
that's what's being sore you're hyper
sore is not sore and I keep telling
people it's like you you're talking
about slow working you jog and you
little Eddy whoever hurt oh you have use
everyone like every huh
you know it's like okay yeah good know
when you do a circuit you wait train and
you put your [ __ ] to the rear up yeah
okay fine
just your ass'll rat yes just your
[ __ ] and that is slothful that's
awful